♪ ♪
>> Sean: I'VE BEEN ON THIS
PROGRAM FOR YEARS AND DOCUMENTED
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT HOW MUCH OF
THE MEDIA SIMPLY EXTENSION OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE ONE TEAM COORDINATING
THE SAME POLITICAL MESSAGES,
MANUFACTURING AND USING THE SAME
WORDS AND ECHO CHAMBER, REPEAT
THE SAME TALKING POINTS AND
TONIGHT, IT IS ON DISPLAY MORE
THAN EVER AFTER THE LEAK OF
RECENT "NEW YORK TIMES" EMPLOYEE
TOWN CALL -- TOWN HALL.
THE LEADERSHIP CAME CLEAN ABOUT
HOW ANTI-TRUMP THEIR AGENDA
REALLY IS.
ALL OF THIS BREATHLESS HYSTERIA
AND ALL THAT THEY PREVIEW COME
ALL THE CONSPIRACY THEORIES THEY
PUSHED, ALL FAKE NEWS NARRATIVES
PUSHED, ALL FAKE NEWS NARRATIVEA
PUSHED, ALL FAKE NEWS NARRATIVEE
UP NEXT.
LIKE I SAID, JOURNALISM HAS BEEN
BURIED SINCE 2007.
I SAID ON THIS PROGRAM.
THEIR CREDIBILITY IS IN CRISIS.
THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
CREDIBILITY AND ESPECIALLY AFTER
TWO AND A HALF YEARS FROM ALL
THE MAJOR NETWORKS, TWO TABLE
NETWORKS, "NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST" WENT WITH THE
BIGGEST LINE CONSPIRACY HOAX IN
MODERN HISTORY.
AND NEVER ADMITTED THEY ARE
WRONG.
AND EVEN THE TIMES IS ADMITTING
THEY WENT ALL IN ON THE
COLLUSION DELUSION WITH
EXECUTIVE EDITOR DEAN McKAY
TELLING EMPLOYEES THAT ONCE
RUSSIA HOAX UNRAVELED THE STORY
OF THE KING, TRICKIER BEFORE
ADDING "WE BUILT OUR NEWSROOM TO
COVER ONE STORY, AND WE DID IT
TRULY WELL."
NO THEY DIDN'T.
THEY WERE PROVEN WRONG.
THEY WERE DISAPPOINTED BY
MUELLER.
WE HAVE TO CHECK RESOURCES AND
EMPHASIS TO TAKE ON A DIFFERENT
STORY.
OH, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN A
DIFFERENT STORY?
IT MEANS THEY SPENT YEARS
PUSHING THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
THERE RATIONALIZE MISINFORMATION
PROPAGANDA ALL TO HELP THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEY FAILED
MISERABLY WITH THERAPIST LICENSE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
NOW THEY HAVE TO FIND A NEW FAKE
NEWS STORY NARRATIVE TO BLUDGEON
THE PRESIDENT.
NO ONE BETTER THAN ANGRY AGENDA
DRIVEN WEARING THEIR UNDERWEAR,
SPEWING THEIR HATE ONLINE EVERY
DAY ALL DAY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS NO
BETTER.
THIS IS THE NEW EXTREME RADICAL
PRESS IN AMERICA.
HATE TRUMPET EVERY SECOND EVERY
MINUTE OF EVERY DAY WHICH WILL
BE RETREATING TO THE OLD
DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINT.
THEY WANT TO NOW GO THROUGH AND
BASICALLY TATTOOED DONALD TRUMP
HE IS A RACIST, RACIST, RACIST,
STORMY, STORMY STORMY RUSSIA
RUSSIA RUSSIA FAILED BECAUSE AT
THE SAME EVENT, YOU HAD ONE
"NEW YORK TIMES" SAY "THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT IS
RACIST, WHAT IS RACIST?
I FEEL LIKE RACISM IS IN
EVERYTHING.
AND CALL OUT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY BEFORE ADDING THE
INDIVIDUAL INSTANCES OF RACISM
AND HOW WE ARE SORT OF THINKING
ABOUT RACISM AND WHITE SUPREMACY
AS THE FOUNDATION OF ALL OF OUR
SYSTEMS IN THE COUNTRY TO WHICH
THE EXECUTIVE EDITOR OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RESPONDED
"THAT RACE IS GOING TO BE A HUGE
PART OF THE AMERICAN STORY IN
THE NEXT YEAR."
TERMS OF NOT ONLY
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAVE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH DONALD TRUMP
BUT LATINOS, AND IMMIGRATION.
OF COURSE JUST CONFIRMS
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU ABOUT THE CORRUPT MEDIA
MOB, THE ANTI-TRUMP CONSPIRACY
THEORY MEDIA.
THE DESIRE ALL REPUBLICANS, ALL
CONSERVATIVES, HOMOPHOBIC
XENOPHOBIC, KILLED CHILDREN,
THROW GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF
AFTER YOU FEED HER WITH A YEAR
WITH DOG FOOD OR CAT FOOD.
IT'S NOT EVERY TWO YEARS OR FOUR
YEARS ANYMORE.
THIS UNHINGED FLY IS A SLANDER
AGAINST CONSERVATIVES THEM.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE AND I FIND
ALL ANTI-SEMITISM REPUGNANT.
HAVE THEY CALLED OUT A LOT OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S HISTORY?
WE HAVE GIVEN THE HISTORY ON THE
SHOW AND I WILL DO IT AGAIN TO
REMIND THEM MAY BE TOMORROW
NIGHT BUT THIS IS ALL THEY DO.
THE DEMOCRATS AND OF COURSE
THEIR FRIENDS AND THE MEDIA WORK
IN CONCERT WITH ONE ANOTHER
BECAUSE BEYOND RUSSIA, THE LIE,
NEVER ADMITTED THEY WERE WRONG
AND NEVER ADMITTED THEY LIED.
AND WILL THEY EVER RETURN THOSE
PULITZER SURPRISES?
THEY ARE TELLING US AHEAD OF
TIME, LISTEN TO THE NEW ECONOMIC
RECESSION, THAT IS ANOTHER
THING, TALK DOWN THE ECONOMY,
WATCH.
>> PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE, THE
PRESIDENT RIGHT WHEN RECESSION
IS NOT ON THE WAY?
HE IS NOT RIGHT BUT RECESSION IS
OKAY.
A RECESSION IS A NORMAL PART OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ATTEMPTING
TO DOWNPLAY GROWING CONCERNS
THAT THE U.S. ECONOMY COULD BE
HEADING FOR A RECESSION.
>> THIS MORNING RECESSION AND
REELECTION, PRESIDENT TRUMP
INSISTING HE HAS NO CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AFTER THAT
800-POINT PLUNGE.
>> JOSH, ISN'T THE FEDS WILL
MAKE THE NEXT ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
WORSE?
WHAT IS YOUR -- >> IT WOULD GET
RID OF TRUMP.
>> RECEPTION -- RECESSION HAS
REALLY BAD AND PEOPLE LOSE THEIR
JOBS.
>> THAT WILL MAKE IT TO HAVE >>
TRUMP LOSES.
THERE YOU GO.
>> LET'S TALK DOWN THE ECONOMY
BECAUSE MUELLER DIDN'T WORK.
THEIR OWN PIECE HEADSET SUMMED
IT UP BEST, FIRST RUSSIA RUSSIA
RUSSIA, RACISM RACISM RACISM
RECESSION RECESSION WRIST
RASH -- RECESSION, STORMY STORMY
IMPEACH IMPEACH, SAME THING
MANUFACTURED CRISIS MANUFACTURED
MANUFACTURED CRISIS MANUFACTUREC
MANUFACTURED CRISIS MANUFACTUREI
MANUFACTURED CRISIS MANUFACTURES
THIS
PROGRAM WE ARE COMMITTED TO
EXPOSING ALL OF THE MEDIA
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OF LIES,
EVERY HOAX, EVERY -- THEY TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
DIVIDE THIS COUNTRY.
REAL CONSERVATIVES, THEY DEPLORE
RACISM FROM THE PERSON THAT HAS
DONE MORE FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION FOR MINORITIES IN
AMERICA, POLICIES THAT HAVE
WORKED BEST AND THE POLICIES OF
DONALD J. TRUMP, FACT, MAYBE
THEY SHOULD PUT THAT IN THEIR
PAPER ONE DAY.
THE COLLUSION DELUSION,
COVINGTON LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO
NICHOLAS -- NICHOLAS SANDMANN
AND JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AND THE
LIES THE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
WITH THE CONSPIRACY THEORY OVERF
WITH THE CONSPIRACY THEORY OVERR
WITH THE CONSPIRACY THEORY OVERU
WITH THE CONSPIRACY THEORY OVERO
WITH THE CONSPIRACY THEORY OVERN
IGNORING THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN OUR
NATIONS HISTORY.
THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO ACT AS IF
NOTHING BUT PARTISAN ACTIVIST IN
A STATE RUN DEMOCRATIC RADICAL
SOCIALIST EXTREMIST TV, RADIO
AND YEAH, PRINT INSTEAD OF BEING
SERIOUS INVESTIGATORS.
THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO PUT FAKE
NEWS, FAKE NARRATIVES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OVER FACTS.
AND CHOSEN TO ATTACK ANYONE WHO
DARED TO CALL OUT THEIR LACK OF
ETHICS AND OBJECTIVITY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO GIVE YOU A
FRONT ROW SEE TO THIS CORRUPTION
AND THE MEDIA.
WE WILL HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AND CONTINUE TO EXPOSE THEM BUT
FRANKLY, THEY EXPOSE THEMSELVES.
FOX CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER,
SLUMP WARS, JEFFREY LAWRENCE,
SARAH, FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS,
WE HAVE HAD AN ENSEMBLE CAST.
YOU AND JEFF HAVE BEEN A PART OF
IT, GREG, JOHN SULLIVAN, AND
JUDGE PIRRO.
WE HAVE TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THE TRUTH.
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS, I'M
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE
PROVEN RIGHT ON A LEVEL THAT
MIGHT TAKE AWAY THE BREATH OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SHOCKED
THE COUNTRY.
BUT THESE LIES GET TOLD AND THEY
DON'T APOLOGIZE.
THEY DON'T ADVISE BUT THEY DO
NOT MAKE A CORRECTION OR APOLOGY
BUT GO TO THE NEXT THING.
THEY ARE TELEGRAPHING IT.
>> SEAN IT IS SHOCKING TO ME.
I REMEMBER WHEN I STARTED AS A
YOUNG REPORTER AT THE DAILY
BULLETIN IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST THING MY EDITOR SAID,
YOU DON'T SHAPE A NARRATIVE BUT
YOU LET THE STORY COME TO YOU.
AS AN INVESTIGATOR, YOU GO OUT,
YOU SEE IT, YOU COLLECT THE
EVIDENCE AND THEN YOU REALLY --
YOU REPORTED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE OR LOCAL COMMUNITY THAT I
WAS COVERING.
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS DONE,
THIS IS THE REASON WHY.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO KNOW THE
TRUTH, SEAN.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DIDN'T WANT
TO KNOW THE TRUTH BECAUSE HAD
THEY WANTED TO KNOW THE TRUTH
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN THERE WITH
US ALL ALONG AND COVERING THE
SAME INFORMATION THAT WE
UNCOVERED THROUGHOUT THE LAST
TWO AND A HALF YEARS ON YOUR
SHOW.
THAT IS JOHN SOLOMON AND I AND
OTHERS REPORTING ON THIS.
DEVIN NUNES DISCOVERED AND WHAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM DISCOVERED.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WOULD HAVE
BEEN THERE BUT THEY WANTED TO
SHAPE THE NARRATIVE.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT IS
ABSOLUTELY FRIGHTENING RIGHT
NOW, WHAT IS REALLY STUNNING
THAT THEY WILL TRY TO SHAPE THE
NARRATIVE ON RACISM.
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY
DANGEROUS -- PARTICULARLY FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT RAN
ANTI-SEMITIC, ANTI-SEMITIC
CARTOON GLOBALLY WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU AND THEY
ACTUALLY HAD TO END THE CARTOON
IN THE NEWSPAPER BECAUSE OF IT.
NOW THEY WILL TRY TO SHAPE THIS
RACIST AGENDA.
AND I WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO REALIZE THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
WRONG.
THIS IS BACKWARDS.
THE EXECUTIVE EDITOR SHOULD BE
ASHAMED, SHOULD BE FIRED, SHOULD
BE FIRED FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
WE SHOULD GET BACK TO REPORTING
REAL STORIES AND LETTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THE
INCIDENCES.
>> Sean: IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
JESSE, YOU WORKED FOR THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU SAY YOU ARE A
CONSERVATIVE AND/OR WHITE WHITE
SUPREMACIST OR A RACIST, NOBODY
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT Y
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT U
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT P
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT R
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT O
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT ,
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT E
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT D
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT O
THAT I KNOW MAINSTREAM SUPPORT F
SENTENCE.
THIS IS A BIG LIE, EVERY TWO AND
FOUR YEARS BUT NOW IT'S EVERY
DAY.
>> THAT IS RIGHT COMMISSION ON
WHAT IS IN "NEW YORK TIMES," IS
IT ASTONISHING IN THE AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THIS IS SOMETHING RUSH LIMBAUGH
HAS TALKED ABOUT FOR YEARS.
AND THE LEFT WANT TO DO A TOTAL
REWRITE OF AMERICAN HISTORY AND
REMAKE THE STORY THAT WERE
FOUNDED IN RACISM AND ITS ALL
ABOUT RACE, ET CETERA, ET CETERA
ET CETERA.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE, WHERE
WERE THEY IN THE --
>> EXACTLY RIGHT, SEAN.
EXACTLY.
SEAN, I READ
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PIECES,
SO-CALLED PROJECT AND THERE'S
NOT A SOLITARY MENTIONED THAT
SLAVERY AND SEGREGATION WERE THE
PARTY OF DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: BUT I WILL SAY THIS,